all right so much for coming I think
there are not I think I'm the only
person speaking this weekend is speaking
about audio I so I think there's
probably not many people around here who
do work with audio can I just see the
show of hands if there's only you do as
a few just all right yes so mostly not
so this is great I bet to I get to sort
of preach the message here because
there's some really really interesting
things you can do is sound we have a
little sound recording playing of a bird
I don't know if you recognize it
anyone recognize it say yes yeah black
dude with the yellow beak it's a really
nice example of bird song so it so I'm
gonna I'm gonna be talking about Huell
of different things but one of the one
of the principal things we might want to
do with bird sound is recognize which
bird is singing the black birds a really
nice example because it's singing this
song repeatedly but it's not making
exactly the same sound every time we can
see there's a general pattern to it and
week I can talk for ages about what the
general pattern might be but it's
actually very difficult to specify and
we can't just sort of say here's a sort
of standard template for this particular
bird type or this particular individual
so lots of really interesting questions
I'm just going to stop the sound for now
so that I can talk with a bit less
distraction
there we go um yes so I'm an academic
and a researcher at Queen Mary so the
mistake machine listening lab is a group
we have Queen Mary University of London
which is about three tube stops from
here so you can come and visit its the
Machine listening lab we're using signal
processing and also machine learning to
try and make sense of sounds and to do
things with sound you might have seen
some of the talks this week and touching
on image processing touching on natural
language processing audio you'll have
seen lots of applications of speech
technology but in general audio is is
really quite underdeveloped there's lots
of audio archives for example which we
can't really get a lot of information
out of because we don't have a lot of
very rich ways of dealing with that data
the same for increasingly there are
sensors everywhere there are lots of
projects where there are audio sensors
continuously monitoring and we'd like
intelligent decisions to be made from
those so a few things that we do in our
lab music transcription we can take
audio signals and in various ways to try
to turn those into a symbolic
representation of what's going on in the
music we did a computer-generated
musical which is one of the slightly
more unusual things we've attempted and
I'm going to be talking about the bird
recognition so today I'm going to be
talking about bird species recognition
and other things and we have all kinds
of questions about that can we decode
the dawn chorus so this is a spectrogram
how many of you are familiar with
spectrograms okay relatively familiar
thank you so yes we've got time here
we've got frequency from low to high and
this is about 10 seconds recorded from a
dawn course there's lots of birds going
on in there all overlapping with each
other all as I said doing different
things every time not necessarily
repeating exactly the same template but
there are lots of questions we want to
ask about it which species as I've said
how many birds are they singing responds
to their neighbors or are they other
warning about predators so there could
be interactions with
the birds and lots of different
questions we want to ask and I'm not
actually it so I come from a background
in computer science and sound processing
I'm not actually an ornithologist but
there are lots of reasons to be asking
these things people from environmental
organizations from monitoring
organizations come to me all the time
asking about how to solve these kind of
questions
because audio monitoring is extremely
useful I'm going to try and show you why
we have this this natural scene here and
we want to detect exactly what sort of
bird is present if you use an image
recognition pipeline you're not going to
get very far
so actually for someone who works in
sound birds are particularly handy thing
to be working on because you can't just
say unlike for recognizing mammals in
the in the undergrowth audio is actually
the best modality for detecting and
analyzing bird sounds as I said there
are people who care about this a lot of
it is in conservation and ecology
monitoring as climate change for example
does make different bird populations
move slightly into different places and
so the ongoing monitoring year by year
we really want to be able to scale that
up work out for example how changes in
ecosystems are changing the the balance
of birds and other animals in different
locations is actually not climate change
isn't the biggest driver in terms of
bird populations but it's actually
changes in farming practices across
Europe and elsewhere that have made the
biggest differences to what's going on
but those have had a dramatic effect on
bird populations and other animals there
are other reasons that we might want to
study bat bird sound another animal
sound partly it's looking at the
evolution of things like language so
humans have this almost unique quality
of learning this complex language during
childhood but actually birds learn
songbirds in particular learn their song
from from tutors during their early
stages and so people are studying the
processes that that lead to this so if
we take large data sets of bird sound
and we can analyze the patterns in those
birds sound and how those progress for
example from generation to generation
can we understand something about
evolution and even language so because
as I said this is an audience that's
relatively unfamiliar with sound I
thought it'd be kind of handy just to
give you some very generic tips so I'm
not going to be talking about speech
recognition a lot I'm not gonna be
talking about speech recognition much at
all it's a very developed field I'm sure
you know it is very specific to the
tasks that are required of speech
recognition so you can't in general take
a speech recognition algorithm and use
it to detect boats going past on the
timers you can't really use it to detect
the to understand the sequences of
sounds that birds are producing and
there are other nice things Shazam I
don't know how much that's well-known
but that's algorithm for identifying
music tracks again that's actually a
very specific algorithm and it said
really interesting algorithm I can tell
you about sometime but these these these
off-the-shelf things that you might know
by name and not actually that useful for
general sounds or for animal sounds the
most common approach in a lot of cases
is to pretend a spectrogram is an image
so there's a spectrogram you could just
pretend that it was a photo of something
and use pretty much any image processing
pipeline you like in general that's not
a bad approach so lots of people who are
doing machine learning applied to any
kind kind of general-purpose sound
recognition task at the moment the a lot
of the leading methods are based on
convolutional neural networks in
particular also recurrent neural
networks applied to the spectrogram as
if pretending it was image there's a few
things that you might miss from that so
I mean firstly I said that this is this
is an image
we've got time along this axis and
frequency along this axis so
thing is Boas are not equivalent axes
they have very very different meanings
so do you really want to treat them the
same in the pipeline that you're
analyzing another thing that's quite
common in sound is harmonics if you have
a sound whose fundamental frequency is
down here it might also be associated
with higher fundamentals and so the
object that is in the image there is
actually sort of spread out across the
image and so if for example you're using
convolutional neural net networks with a
sort of a local field of attention then
there are there are losses in simply
using a standard off-the-shelf pipeline
they're tools so we use all the standard
Python machine learning libraries the
the main thing which might be new to you
I'm gonna say is Lib Roza which is a
really handy library for loading and
saving audio files of various sorts for
producing spectrograms
or also for doing things like well
actually a wide variety of features not
just spectrograms but a lot of the kind
of standard things that people who do
audio signal processing use everyday so
it's really as simple as that in terms
of libraries so I'm happy to recommend
that I'm gonna tell you then about sort
of the story of how we took bird species
classification did some research on it
and then turned it into an app which we
know sell in the UK and it's called
wobbler the idea is you have the app on
your phone you don't know what that
Blackbird is so you record 10 seconds of
it and then that sends it to our server
we give you an answer there's so I'm an
academic and I did this work this sort
of commercialization work partly partly
as a way of actually making some things
to making the initiative sustainable
because in academia we can have a
project that lasts for two years and
then just goes off a cliff I wanted to
see this as a thing that people could
use and that people could sort of and
that would be an ongoing project that
would just be you know it's just some
until that you would have a new phone we
also work with open data and we have as
part of the way we design the system we
have a kind of a give-and-take where we
say that people who contribute audio
recordings to this their recordings will
be published anonymously as open data
and so we're building with this
initiative open datasets of birds sound
recordings that can be used for various
research purposes so there's a nice kind
of give-and-take there we built it as a
commercial project but not not as
straightforward here's a thing you can
buy a commercial project so we want to
take 10 seconds of bird sound and
predict what sort of bird it is that
kind of thing has been done in the past
in some research papers but actually if
you if you think about what's practical
these kind of let's say in the 2000s
research papers would do things like
they would classify between ten
different bird species but there be
really clean recordings and it was it's
not got any background noise on it not
really useful if you go out with your
mobile phone into some nearby forest
those actually potentially more than 200
species that either live in the UK or
pass through the UK that you potentially
might hear and if you go to the tropics
there are even more so so really if we
if you're designing a bird classifier
it's a pretty large number of classes
and of course there might be more than
one bird active at a time so just
briefly this is this is just a kind of a
case study of how we specifically
engineered some features to lead to good
learning in the in the case of bird
sounds so that Blackbird example I was
played you at the start we have we don't
know we don't have an exact template
that we can work with and as I said with
the sort of full full range of
frequencies there might be information
in different frequency bands what I'm
going to just talk you through very
quickly is a kind of feature learning
process that we used which is a little
bit like a kind of
convolutional filter so here's a
spectrogram and for the input data we're
simply going to divide it up into frames
but they're going to be full height
frames so the full frequency with let's
say about 10 or 20 milliseconds of time
and oh yeah this is in slightly the
wrong order let me do it this way so
then what we want to do is actually
learn a basis set a set of features on
which we can sort of project that data
and so we're learning that from from the
types of very brief as I said 10 or 20
milliseconds the type of very brief
gestures that birds tend to make in
audio and hear from a large amount of
birdsong unlabeled we've learned some
typical things that go on there's a lot
of individual frequencies there there's
also some interesting stuff like here
we've got a kind of downward chirp so
we've got a slightly very
stereotypically birdy sound you've got a
downward going chirp that also has some
harmonics on top of it as well so we're
learning sort of what tends to be going
on in these bird sounds and then we take
the data and then we project it back
onto this basis set so it's basically
just a matrix projection but it's
actually taking the data and
transforming it into a way that actually
represents it in a way that the
differences between different species
are actually emphasized and those a
relatively micro level okay we repeat
that twice in our case - - to have a
sort of low level and a slightly higher
level version in order to do that we've
got some handy little algorithms I'm
just going to point at these because
they're keep algorithms that I think
people should know maybe you do already
I don't know I don't know but of course
we had a lot of data and too much data
to store in memory this this algorithm
this first one here is just really
simple but a nice streaming algorithm to
take a uniform random sample of data
you've got a billion data points you
stream them through once and you want to
take a uniform random sample from those
billion there's a very very simple
algorithm from the 60s or 70s
reservoir random sampling which just
does it in about let's see I think it's
about 15 lines of code and so I've just
got to get hub there and in order to to
estimate these templates let me call
them we used a kind of k-means
clustering so you can do k-means
clustering in an online fashion you've
got a billion points you stream through
and is through months and you've got
your k centroids the difference here
with us is that is actually something
called spherical k-means so instead of
with with ordinary k-means you're
estimating sort of the the centroids of
these clusters with spherical k-means
were actually estimating unit vectors so
we're not just estimating where the data
are but unit vectors that point towards
the data and that actually just makes it
magnitude invariant so what that means
is that each of these are though they
don't look like unit vectors they're
actually you know if you vectorize them
they're just unit vectors and that's
that's the basis on which we reap
rejecting them so that's the fundamental
algorithm I haven't gone into a lot of
detail of that you can ask me questions
afterwards but then it worked basically
we submitted it to an international
classification challenge and it got
surprisingly good results which is what
leaders actually towards thinking it was
actually worth putting onto people's
phones and we produced this app so this
is now commercial it's been selling for
two and a half years now in the UK it's
been doing really well and we're about
to launch a US version as I said you
record ten seconds of sound it gives you
a ranked list of what species it thinks
it thinks it is the architecture we went
for something pretty simple and the the
so the architecture is is pretty much a
separation between the the the phone app
and the sort of the
the cloud surface that's backing it so
the the the phone app is is not doing
any of the machine learning side of
things we simply send the audio to the
server there are a few different reasons
for that one of them is because as I
said we're not we want to collect this
audio data to open datasets and so are
aggregating all of that data the other
and then we send the bird species
decision back of course over simple rest
request the real advantage there
absolutely massive advantage that we had
was that to go from research to
deployment was really really
straightforward my code was already in
Python a lot of SK learn and things like
that and we simply wrapped it in a
pyramid words at web service and there
you go
I gave us loads of advantages such as
being able to improve the system without
having to redeploy the phone up and so
on the biggest criticism we had was that
if you're out in the forest and you
don't have any Wi-Fi connection or
something like that then you can't use
the bird recognition that's just a cost
that we faced we were gambling on data
streaming services getting better and
better and that not turned out ok so
yeah people started using it we've got
these these stats are a little bit old
actually now but we've got 5000 6000
paying users lots and lots of recordings
get 80 per day more in the spring than
in the winter you know things like that
it's basically fine and not being a very
commercially minded person I haven't
done a lot of these kind of sort of
launches of products before and I
learned something about like what people
do when they get their hands on
technology so as I said you record 10
seconds of sound and it predicts what
bird it thinks it is immediately after
launch we've got a few interesting bits
of feedback like this they tested the
Warbler app on the photocopier and so
yeah I mean this is a really nice
example but the other side effect which
was really surprising is so as I said
you record 10 seconds of sound and we
collected these things as a result we
now I think have possibly the largest
database of bird
oppressions in the and we're trying to
think of something interesting to do
with that data so yeah we can recognize
bird from a bird from someone whistling
the sound I don't know maybe so yeah
that's that's that sort of the first
story on to tell you about about
automatic bird species classification
and so we released it so we did the
research on that and then we released it
as an app for people to use it does also
relate to sort of ecological monitoring
projects and so you know with with data
sets that people record out in the
forest we want to go ahead and sort of
use that for for larger projects I'm
going to talk about I'll give you a
couple of very brief postcards of sort
of active research and I'm going to talk
about something to do with bird
detection which is hopefully uh
hopefully something that you could even
get engaged and if you wanted to so one
of the things we're working on at the
moment is actually what partly related
to the problem that we have so little
data so if you work with speech you're
extremely lucky because so many
databases of annotated speech people
transcribe the speech people translate
transcribe the speech in multiple
languages with animal sound bird so we
don't have that we have to work with
either completely unsupervised data
obviously we don't actually know what
the birds are saying to each other but
also with data that might be weekly
labels so on the left-hand side you see
we've got actually what what typically
happens when you have a bird watcher out
in the field they'll they'll they'll
have a list and they'll say I saw a
Robin I saw a black bird I didn't see
one of these but actually what we want
especially in my archive applications so
for example the British Library has this
fantastic big sound archive of natural
sound but that is weakly labeled it just
says there is a Robin in this recording
somewhere we'd like in order to in order
for actual data mining to be useful we'd
like to know where in the sound
recordings as those are and so we're
working on this sort of paradigm of
being able to make inferences from
weakly labeled data so that's that's a
nice
prospect that you can train a system
even though the training data isn't as
precise as you would like that's
something that we've just submitted I'm
just going to leave that there for now
similarly I'm just briefly going to talk
about sequences so birds sing are often
in sequences of units and we'd like to
make sense of that in the long term we
would like to know what birds are saying
to each other is what's the information
content in there and so for the birds as
I said earlier we can't
straightforwardly just use a speech
recognition pipeline one of the reasons
is that there's often lots of birds
singing at once and of course lots of
people would like to be able to decode
multiple speakers at once and that's
that's still a hard problem with bird
sounds we do things like we take a
sequence of bird sounds and we want to
automatically predict which which sound
belongs to which bird and so it's
related to source separation it's
actually just detecting a kind of sort
of graphical in terms of graph theory
kind of connection from one zone to
another so we can start to we can start
to look at sequences and how they
influence each other so that's an
ongoing thing I just wanted to give you
a little postcard of it because we do
classification we do detection we do
these other things I'm not today talking
about some of the more intricate uses of
machine learning because I wanted to be
I wanted to give an overview of these
different topics um I want to go to
possibly the simplest thing which is
bird detection so apparently it's a
simple question are there any birds in
this audio clip now is that an easier
question or a harder question than what
species of bird is in this audio clip
easier harder yeah it's I like the fact
that you sort of even we split there
because I'm evenly split it's like if
you if you think of
this is a binary classification problem
birds no birds the birds class is this
really difficult class which basically
has everything and it has black birds it
has Al's it has all the crazy birds you
could ever detect so while on the other
hand there are commonalities between
these birds right so there should be
some advantages as well as disadvantages
but the fundamental point is that
answering this question is really really
useful especially for data mining large
data sets where birds are sparsely
present we'd like to detect animal
sounds so that we can either manually
inspect them or to process them later
so there are detectors out there you can
use a kind of sort of template detector
to detect a bird a specific bird but the
real gap in the state of the art is
actually doing that generally so last
year we designed a sort of data
challenge we published some open data
and a public baseline and we challenged
people to produce a system that could
that could perform this so if you've
ever worked with data challenges before
this is the sort of the classic machine
learning data challenge setup where we
give you some training data with labels
we give you some test data without
labels and the challenge is to actually
get their answers right in order to make
this a difficult task for generalization
we we took we had training data part of
the training data actually came from the
phone oh right so we have this data
recorded on mobile phones around the UK
all kinds of different parts of the UK
and that was the training data for the
testing data we had all kinds of other
things so we had an entire remote
monitoring data set from Chernobyl where
there is a hot an exclusion zone where
people aren't allowed to go and so we
have remote monitoring there and what
surprised me was that people still got
pretty good results so this is each each
of these dots is a different sort of
competitor in the challenge and the
results were getting up to about 90
percent really pretty good we're
rerunning this again this year and this
is partly why I wanted to talk about
this this is a challenge that you can
take part in so
last year oh it's um well it's actually
the year before last now but we so we
run this challenge we had prizes for the
we had prizes for the best submission we
also have prizes for the most
interesting submission because we really
didn't want just a whole pile of the
same convolutional neural network
submitted so it was great to see diverse
approaches and we're doing this again
this year so it's part of a larger
initiative it's called D case which is
detection and classification of audio
scenes and events there are five
different tasks so there are there are
new open datasets big datasets of audio
that you can download and we have
baseline
deep learning code you'll you'll
recognize it as often I think all of the
baselines are in chaos and you can
download it from D Coast community there
is a challenge for bird sound there is a
challenge for I think Endor home event
detection things like that yes I guess
that's it I so I've kind of haven't
really finished the story on that DK's
thing sorry so the we've got we've got
more data we've got more data collecting
data from the USA and other data and so
the real challenge is generalization I
think one thing that's been really
interesting in this weekend for me has
been the the practical application and
evaluation of methods and so in a lot of
talks that I've seen it's not enough if
a system seems to get a particular
percentage it's actually whether it
actually works in your in your business
case or data that is non-stationary
and that's what we're trying to aim at
here so we're really trying to improve
the state of the art so it's not just
about getting a particular percentage
but about being able to generalize and
be able to do a job that basically that
when some ecologist downloads your data
and goes to use it in Australia we can
expect that it will get a pretty good
result so a lot of this is open
open source and open data we do go for
open copyleft licenses as much as we can
and so there's plenty of stuff to play
with and I hope that I've shown you a
bit that there's a there's a lot of
different challenges and this is just in
bird sound I mean you can also think
about analyzing cattle sounds or outdoor
sounds you know along the river along
the street there are some industrial
applications starting to come in so part
of that some of that actually comes from
smart cars with audio detection on smart
cars there are a few different things
well so many different things in audio
analysis and I hope that through through
these open datasets you'll be inspired
to just have a little dabble and see
what you can do I'm gonna acknowledge
Frank the the different sort of parking
tools and libraries who use so I
mentioned Lib rosa for audio processing
in terms of machining we are sort of
using oh I didn't put scikit-learn on
the list it well anyway so we've got we
are sort of using these sort of three
different kind of paradigms listen we do
plenty in Karis intensive level so there
was piano and lasagna anyone with
lasagna here yeah
sorry I know I know I know I just I just
like lasagna but so yeah I know
everyone's on Keros intensive flow these
days so I just wanted to save a little
bit of a EA anyway and yeah thanks to
pyramid as well for letting us turn our
research code straight into a web
service that's great you can download
the slides there and that's me that's
the app and that's the data challenge
we've got plenty of time left so I hope
you've got questions about bird sound I
think we're good we should do it that
way so thank you
[Applause]
thank you for your awesome talk very
interesting just a small technical
question one your graph where you have
the spectrogram so what is your max
frequency is the area under curve I mean
I mean like you're you you've got your
you know - no no no on your spectrograms
the spectrogram and you go like you know
you got windows of 50 milliseconds but
what is your max frequency and you know
is that like what frequency do you go up
to so we're actually using standard CD
quality sense that's 44 kilohertz
sampled and then what you see here and
actually yes so what we're doing
actually in order to do a little bit of
data compression we've taken the
standard spectrogram and then we've
actually compressed it into the mel
spectrogram which might be a word you're
familiar with it's a slightly warped
frequency axis but then it is going from
about a hundred Hertz here well yeah you
know it's a wee high pass filter it for
the bird sound so we're starting from
about 500 Hertz here and then it is
going up to the 22 at the top followed
of speech applications you can get away
with just using the lower frequency
bands for birds you can't because there
are a lot of the gold crest I think
sings that like 10 kilohertz or 12
kilohertz
so you do have to be careful so sorry
for that 10 or 12 kilohertz you know
that the if the fundamental is 10 or 12
kilohertz then there are harmonics way
beyond 22 kilohertz but in general
cd-quality is okay for bird sound cool
thank you hi if you were to open-source
your product and offer it to all the
bird aficionados all around the UK in
the world will you be able to basically
use it for sustainability projects I'm
not sure I understand that cause and
affecting the question there what what's
the what's the busy bee given as a to
to the community in order to basically
spot birds yeah have actually proved
that this bird was spotted in a certain
location and then basically use hard
facts to go to the government and say
okay these areas Harbor so and so many
birds and so on yeah yes yes you could
do you could do we so in terms of the
simple sustainability of the project
that does I mean this is a big question
I was really going back and forth on
whether it's a fully open source or not
and we went for this commercialization
route because I think actually in
practice it does make it a more
sustainable project in ecology and
conservation we're working with a lot of
people who might actually know a fair
bit of our but but don't know how to do
machine learning or to work with these
other things so there's certainly a
question of who and how is going to
sustain a service like that in terms of
the evidence for things at the moment a
lot of the evidence comes directly from
sort of manual surveying and that's not
very scalable but it does have certain
reliability guarantees that we don't
have from automatic detection so there's
still some questions around that machine
learning often gives fuzzy results so
there's others there error bars and the
how to incorporate all those error bars
together into into creating things that
should guide government policy that's
still something which we have a lot of
discussions with statistical ecologists
about thanks for the talk really like
the Warbler idea just wondering do you
or have you thought about using the GPS
location for building you know improving
the delicious yeah I got a story about
that yes we do so so thanks to the
British trust for ornithology who have
been doing some of this manual surveying
for decades they have a map of where we
expect to see particular birds they
allowed us to use that data so we have
this kind of we have the GPS location
and we have a bit
that gives us a bit of a prior now the
issue with that is that if you give
people an app to recognize bird sounds
the first thing they'll do is play sound
from their laptop and the GPS location
isn't expected isn't isn't leading to an
expectation of a kookaburra in in West
London the the other thing that that
happens that's unexpected is that people
go to Camden world to London Zoo in
Camden and the data doesn't actually
tell you about London Zoo either so
there are pros and cons to using that
but we do we collect the GPS data and we
do we do use it and it does apart from
those caveats it does help to pin down
the the decision yeah great oh thanks
maybe you said it I missed it but how do
you acquire your training data set and
did you ever think of using wobbler in
order to get input from the user
in order to label yeah absolutely
so the part of the dough I'm going the
wrong way in the slides here part of the
design we really wanted the user journey
to be really really simple because this
is this is this expert birders don't
need the app expert birders can already
hear what they're hearing but this is
for ideally for the general public to go
what's that sound
it's that so we tried to keep the the
user journey as simple as possible we
there is an option to give feedback on
whether the results are right or not but
given what I've just said you'll
understand people don't usually know if
the if the answer is right or not so we
have less than 1% of the data people
give feedback on oh and you also asked
where the training data came from
there's a project based in the
Netherlands called C no Kanto which is
basically just a big crowd source
database of bird recordings so we
started with that there's some
interesting questions around there
that's that's actually Creative Commons
licensed content
and we're there's a lot of
head-scratching about whether we were
allowed to use it to train a commercial
system we came to the conclusion that we
were and with friends with the project
anyway so so that came through ok thanks
for the talk you said that be expert
birders know what they're hearing
so can you beat that experts level
performance and recognize them greater
with the current state of the art no no
we can't we can't beat a real expert
bird the let's see if I can well I don't
think the spectra drums here are really
going to show the point that I want to
make but one thing is that the data is
audio data is very very subtle in the
sense that if there's a bird near you
there's going to be quite prominently
present in the data and that that we can
we can equal expert birders but the
place where any algorithmic paradigm you
care to mention doesn't do very well
people with not only their stereo
hearing but also their contextual
knowledge a very good hearing a sound a
kilometer or in a forest and it's
extremely difficult to come up with an
approach that's going to actually do
that in machine learning terms you know
because in signal terms this very very
distant sound is so embedded in the
noise it's really hard to distinguish
accurately
just out of curiosity do you know how
much information you actually add by the
spectrogram or have you tried different
spectrograms
so how much information we so
technically you could just put in the
time series which would contain the same
information as a spectrogram do just
have you ever played around with that
yes so the well well the first thing to
say is that the we tried we tested the
classifier directly on the spectrogram
we tested it on on the sort of the the
learnt features that I told you about we
also tested it on a sort of a reduced
version of the spectrogram which used to
be common it's called M FCC's but anyway
sort of sort of data reduced version of
the spectrogram and the the feature the
feature learning does improve results
the spectrogram from again provides more
information than the M FCC's so there is
an improvement there on the raw audio
data not directly on our data sets but
but there are various tests in in sort
of machine learning applied to audio
which do go directly from the Royal
waveform it can be useful especially you
have extremely large data sets which
typically just means speech data sets
but if you look at what's happening in
the first layer of learning they're
typically learning something a lot like
a frequency representation that is very
similar to a male spectrogram so it
could help but only if you have a whole
pile of spare GPUs that you need to
learn I think we're we're out of time
for questions but I would like to take
our speaker and thank you
you